[музика]
лікує бачу майбутнє України це
прогресивна країна яка буде більш
популярна то ми можемо бути більш
творчими більш космолітичними
і я вважаю що тільки світле майбутнє її
очікуємо після перемоги в першу чергу я
хочу повернутися в рідне місто до
окупованого Каховку хочу побачити з
дідусем сходити на пасіку з Днем хочу
побачити свою квартиру в якій я виросла
свою школу в якій навчалась і звичайно
побачити з друзями
Привіт Мене звати Ольга мої основне
захоплення музика
[музика]
через війну мені довелося переїхати до
Берліна у мене було відсутнє бажання
співати починати щось нове і цікавитися
чимось крім новин і війни
Коли я повернулася до Києва до мене
раптово повернулася бажання співати і
створювати музику у місті де немає часу
на довгі роздуми у місті де всі працюють
задля Перемоги України
Я хотіла б сьогодні зустрітися для
таксистів і познайомити з ними
[музика]
ще рік тому ці жуки стояли по всьому
Києву вони захистили нас від російських
танків наразі велика кількість з них вже
їде кудись на склади але війна триває
тому більшість все що залишається в
місті
потримаєш
за вікном сьогодні нас не виминити на
вулицю
[музика]
п'ятий фільм пішов ти що давно хотіли
так не знайшов
архітекторка Софія придумала як
пристосувати їх до реального життя
Привіт Привіт Мене звати Софія Я
архітекторка волонтерів в організації
космос табір
це все-таки командна була робота моя
частина була саме за проектувати та
зрозуміти яким чином їжак може
перетворитися заради користі громади Та
взагалі містян
космос табір прямо спочатку повна
масштабного вторгнення
перекваліфіцієвался з такого творчого
творчої організації в таку оборонну
і вони почали з металу саме варити ці
їжаки робити пічки ну все-все-все
наоборону міста
[музика]
коли до нас почали повертатися в наш
штаб їжаки Ми почали думати що з цим
робити І вирішили це може бути корисним
і зараз воєнний час і навіть після
воєнний можна з них з їжаків виготовляти
багато різних вуличних меблів такі як
лавки в парковки столи стільці
[музика]
один з хлопців котрий запропонував мені
цей їжак він робить велосипедні сумки з
перероблених камер а потім він просто
запропонував кажу В мене є їжак
велопарковка хочеш мити у тебе тут
поставимо і я Так звісно
пригода на пригоді
[музика]
оце стиль це зацікавленість є
самовідслідкувати події за кордоном в
Києві це унікальне єдине місце в Києві
люди не дуже хочуть бачити їжаків бо це
все ж таки нагадування про війну а ми
всі хочемо щоб війна закінчилася
я можу запропонувати декілька дизайнів
велопарковки котрі набагато краще їжаки
нікому неприємно бачити але от зі
сторони того як це може бути месенджером
це дуже важливо як на мене і тому їх
треба робити і треба їх не доробити не
для нас їх треба розповсюдити по світу
отак це має бути фактично меморіал
я дійсно здивована що вже один зараз
об'єктів Софії стоїть в Берліні а я його
ще не бачила Тому зараз є можливість
подзвонити Лілі в Берлін
Привіт Олю Привіт Ліля
а можна тебе попросити будь ласка
показати лавку Де ти взагалі зараз
знаходишся а залюбки я знаходжуся біля
брендебрівських воріт і прямо навпроти
них в пілецькому інституті це
більше нам сприяє захисту демократичних
цінностей а саме в цій війні знаходиться
та сама лавка
так
виїжджати в принципі можна її потрогати
і посидіти на ній
Слухай а взагалі як легко зайти в цей
інститут чи всі можуть туди потрапити
абсолютно кожна людина може сюди зайти а
і побачити окрім лавки в принципі ще
інформацію про Україну Так що тут
відбувається Заходи які організовує
організацію волонтерів з України відше
насправді мені трошки
мабуть хотілося щоб такі лавки
знаходилися будь-які у кожній
європейській столиці і можливо навіть на
відкритому повітрі щоб кожна дійсно
людина яка проходить вздовж так би
мовити вздовж не пройшла а зупинилася і
замислилася скажи чи плануєш сюди
приїхати в Берлін
Ну насправді так планую не назавжди Я
дуже хочу відвідати знову в Берлін на
деякий час може але потім знову ж
повернутися в Київ до комфорту і дуже
подобається але обов'язково приїду цей
план клас чекатиму на тебе
навзаєм Гарного дня па-па
[музика]
всі танцюють
Привіт мене звати Ліля Я народилася та
вирізала на сході України на великому
промисловому містечку біля Донецька вже
більше 8 років триває війна в моєму
рідному місті
будучи підлітком Я завжди хотіла виїхати
з Авдіївки так називається моя маленька
містечко 16 років Я переїхала до Києва а
в 2022 році після того як Росія
вторглася в Україну Я приїхала в Берлін
я сумую за миром в рідному місті зараз
та майже все зруйновано немає електро та
водопостачання опалення та газу люди
живуть в підвалах та бомбусховищах
сьогодні Я зустрічаюся з Олександрою
вона також родом зі Сходу України з
Маріуполя і її дім також майже повністю
зруйновано російською війною але те що
знаю зі ЗМІ вона бачила На власні очі що
таке війна і як вона її Переживає І чи
можливо будувати майбутнє Після
пережитого
[музика]
що для мене війна
перша думка це бред
Це просто нездатність людей розмовляти
нездатність вести комунікацію дипломатію
це просто
помилка
Фатальна
жахлива
смертельна помилка
Олександр розповіла що вся Її родина вже
багато років є активними членами
Червоного Хреста під час війни вони
забезпечували людей їжею та водою та
лікарні медикаментами щодня вона була в
дорозі разом з сестрою ризикуючи життям
15 березня Олександра покинула місто
те що вона побачила в Маріуполі назавжди
залишиться в її пам'яті
всі ці думки вони дуже швидко мені
здається вживляються в твій розум а
потім дуже повільно з нього виходять
коли ти вже безпечному середовищі тому я
ще дуже часто бачила Просто ви уяві такі
картинки що от я їду в автобусі я так
снаряд сюди прилітає і воно все так
прилетела сюда А мы были в это время тут
зараз Олександра перебуває тут у
Німеччині
стосовно того щоб
допомагати якось на місцях я теж про це
дуже багато думала бо мені душею дуже
сильно хочеться але головою і розумію що
в мене нічого немає в моєї сім'ї типу
зараз нічого немає
Ані квартири
взагалі просто нуль у Маріуполі
Олександра була у вітрильному клубі зі
своїм хлопцем Майже щодня вони вдвох
виходили в Азовське море цього літа Вони
хотіли Відкрити власну школу
відкрильного спорту це була її найбільша
Мрія на майбутнє але почалася війна мрія
була розбита вщент клуб був зруйнований
а їхні човен згорів ти думаєш в людей В
Україні будуть сили після війни
відбудовувати державу тож я не знала що
в нас стільки сили є Я думаю ніхто цього
не знав що в українців є так багато
вирішили що ми так мобілізувалися я
починаю плакати кожного разу коли про це
говорю мене це дуже заворожує Я не знаю
це як якась магія про яку ти завжди
мріяв побачити в реальному житті і тут і
бачиш що за три дні там збирають не
супутники на
супутники що люди на машини на
обладнання на
машини швидкої допомоги і все це
робиться отак кожного дня
тисячі різних фондів і постійних хтось
кудись знати щось відбувається і
я не знала що в нас є стільки сили тому
так я впевнена що не відбудову буде
[музика]
з лютого 2022 року Росія атакує Україну
люди гинуть або змушені виїжджати їхні
будинки зруйновані але тут є багато
людей які бачать в Україні набагато
більше ніж жертв російської війни вони
вже сьогодні працюють задля майбутнього
України
[музика]
[оплески]
Мене звати Валентин я технічний директор
і засновник компанії Реліф ми компанія
яка виготовляє папір і упаковку з
опалого листя Я приїхав з України але
зараз живу у Франції у греблі де
займаюся дослідженнями
міста щороку породжують багато листя тож
ми навчилися використовувати ці
біовідходи щоб отримати з них целюлозу
яку можна перетворити на папір
ми використовуємо у 15 разів менше води
під час процесу виділення волокна крім
того ця технологія скорочує викиди CO2
на
78%. ми також на відбілюємо інші волокна
Тому це робить нас більш екологічними
значна частина України зосереджена на
війні але бізнес продовжує робити те що
робив до війни якщо ви не можете
допомогти безпосередньо у вирішенні
проблеми яка стосується війни Ви повинні
зробити усе що можете тому в нашому
випадку ми робимо те що можемо ми просто
виробляємо папір ми просто продаємо
папір і просто платимо податки
Україна завжди була дуже близькою до
Європи за своїм менталітетом за веденням
бізнесу та інфраструктурою
Це дійсно так схоже і після закінчення
війни Я думаю що Україна буде частиною
Європейського Союзу і ми можемо принести
багато корисного досвіду для
Європейського Союзу для бізнесу як
зробити ці підприємства сильнішими тому
що зараз коли у нас є проблеми з
електроенергією з логістикою з газом і
ще з чимось ми все одно займаємося своєю
справою Отже ми сильні ми гнучкі і
хочемо йти до Європейського Союзу ми
можемо поділитися цим досвідом з іншими
людьми
[музика]
Київ це місто яке хоче будувати плани
незважаючи на те що плани руйнуються
щодня Київ - це місто де живуть
неймовірні і талановиті люди
це використані електронні сигарети такий
подарунок Здавалося б нікому не
сподобається за винятком людей яким він
справді потрібен
Мене звати Іван Волинець я програміст
коли почалась війна тоді ми згуртувались
командою ітівцями вступили в кіберборону
мені здавалося цього валу хотілося якось
іще допомагати і коли ми відкрили
електронні сигарети і
почали тестувати ці акумулятор виявилось
що там дійсно літійований акумулятори
повноцінні нормальні які можна
розряджати заряджати дуже багато разів
тобто і так вирішили робити повербанки
Так пацани кіт заряджає
в таких умовах
акумулятори Ми витягаємо з електро
нної сигарети по ємності в області
що це вас
це ми називаємо акумулятори які
непрацездатні які нікуди не годяться
вони йдуть потім на утилізацію це сама
ходова наша модель повербанку
вкладається із 40 акумуляторів від
електронних сигарет
[музика]
починали мої друзі там моя надзвичайно
Наталія друзі колеги в одному лисі та
Наталія А я не корю абсолютно не могла
уявити бо я художник і я взагалі в іншій
сфері А я зараз буду розбирати цигарки
Фіксики
[музика]
ще Юрій який нам надає це приміщення і
всіма можливими способами
допомагає Ось і нам допомагають вже не
мало волонтерів по всій Україні навіть з
інших країн нам присилають електронні
цигарки нам приходять донати ось тому
кожну суботу ми збираємось разом з
волонтерами Тут зазвичай десь біля 20
людей збираються
[музика]
за оцей один день в тиждень ми можемо
зробити там 30-40 павербанків навіть
більше виходило
перспективи в проекту є однозначно вони
дуже великі так як це не тільки
створення дешевших повербанків ніж є на
ринку також це утилізація
акумуляторів утилізації електронних
сигарет які їх забруднюють нашу планету
дивлячись на народ України там до війни
і зараз то люди дуже сильно згуртовані
патріотичні стали і Саме цей Фактор не
може не радувати Бо Україна зараз буде
розвиватися набагато стрімкіше у дуже
багатьох сферах
[музика]
десь саме сюди прилетіли ракети
внаслідок чого шестеро людей загинуло
були вибиті вікна і все було пошкоджено
[музика]
До речі я бачу нову кав'ярню запитаємо у
власника як він відкрив цю кав'ярню у
цей важкий час особливо в центрі Києва
Доброго дня Доброго дня Ходімо
Ми навіть коли відкрили кав'ярню в
перший день з'їли з партнером пили каву
і вголос сказали ну це так круто Це ми
хлопці з Донецьку відкрили свою власну
кав'ярню в самому серці Привіт мене
звати антополіщук Я власник мережі
кав'ярень одну з яких і зараз ми тут
знаходимось ми відкрили вже після
початку повномасштабної війни ми
навесні мали цікаві приміщення які
здавалося які шукали нових орендарів в
мирні часи Ми би
не отримали би ці квадратні метри бо тут
працював успішний бізнес а тепер
працюємо ми
нас коли почалась історія з
повномасштабним вторгненням виїхали всі
Звісно що той зв'язок між компаніями та
людьми які зараз працюють за кордоном
які працюють в Європі які виїхали Він
дуже міцний і Я впевнений що їх капітал
які вони зароблять там Той досвід який
вони отримують він стане потужним
бустером для розвитку
України яка переможена вже є класні
приклади українських бізнесів які
відкриваються ну в першу чергу в Польщі
Львівські круасани і джибари і так далі
я виїжджав на
10 днів за межі України по справах я був
Португалії по фотографіях страв які я
побачив кліпи давайте по тому як
готуються Ці страви по тому як тебе
сервісять
зрозумів що це не місцеві Я підійшов до
команди спитав Звідки ви з України
українці зараз дають всі дуже такий
класний приклад
справжнього сервісу вони навіть навчають
ну це цим ми зараз теж можемо бути
корисними
[музика]
Я дуже хочу щоб
українське телебачення кіно вийшло на
світовий рівень і
українське кіно і українську продукцію
бачили по всьому світу і вона
розвивалася Мені 24 роки я народилася у
незалежній Україні і ми розвивалися з
нею разом і я це бачила на власному очі
Тому я бажаю Україні просто щоб її
залишилось в спокої і все інше
ми зробимо Я би хотіла щоб всі мої
близькі люди повернулись до України я з
ним би усіма зустрілись і обійняла і
поговорила б з ним про майбутнє України
[музика]
у Берліні настрій багатьох українців
схоже гірше ніж у Києві не дивно адже
більшість з них походять з території які
зараз є окупованими зміст який лежать в
руїнах їхнє майбутнє невизначене як
майбутнє Олександри А що з тими хто
травмований війною яким буде українське
суспільство в майбутньому після того як
люди пережили стільки страждань Я їду до
центру убелебень у Берліні Люди які
пережили насильство та втечу знаходять
тут медичну та психотерапевтичну
підтримку
Минулого року українські фахівці
волонтери також прийшли там підготовку
саме з питань подолання наслідків травми
у подальшому вони допомагатимуть людям з
України Тут у мене призначена зустріч з
Юрієм містерко він психолог співкерівник
наукового відділу і також родом з
України
розкажіть чи є подібні приклади
подолання травм викликаних військовими
конфліктами і чи можна це співставити із
ситуацією яка зараз відбувається в
Україні
є дослідження Голокосту тобто
дослідження про тих хто вижив
про покоління їхніх дітей та онуків
інший приклад із новітньої історії війни
на території колишньої Югославії
саме там відбулися події які асоціюються
із подіями в Україні
на жаль це схоже конфлікт
коли насильство походить від сусіда
якому насправді довіряли
[музика]
Юрій розповідає Що те що люди пережили в
Україні матиме вплив на їхніх дітей та
онуків І що існує багато різних форм
насильства з якими доводиться працювати
[музика]
про що ми дедалі частіше чуємо в Україні
це різні форми сексуального насильства і
це форма травми яка несе в собі
найбільше табу та стигматизацію
відчувають труднощі і говорити через
страх через сором і відчувають сильний
опір коли починають говорити
[музика]
скажи чому важливо захищати найбільш
незахищені верстви населення наприклад
ЛГБТ к+
ми знаємо що як ти сказала люди які
вважають себе належними до спектру ЛГБТ
к+ зазнавали різноманітних форм
травматизації щодо конфлікту
під час війни ця вразливість множиться
через просту інакшість якщо суспільство
після такого серйозного потрясіння змозі
допомогти найслабшим тоді таке
суспільство на мій погляд на правильному
шляху
яким бачить своє майбутнє представники
української LG bt-q і а+ спільноти які
зараз тут і що має змінитися на їхню
думку в Україні після війни
я відвідуючі вона музикантка І приїхала
до Берліну разом зі своєю партнеркою
[музика]
зараз я пишу пісні українською і ці
треки так само гидотно звучать як і
треки російською мовою тому що дуже
важко написати гидотний текст
українською
[музика]
коли попробуй жерлити
що зараз ти більше
використовуєш займенник вона по
відношенню себе коли це саме відбулося
якщо ти вдягаєшся
викликаючи для суспільства то тобі треба
бути готовим захищати себе ось тому
багато моїх друзів носили з собою газові
балончики тому що поліція також не дуже
допомагає в цих випадках тому коли я
приїхала в Берлін була така можливість
можна сказати
забути про цей
стрес із сконцентруватися на собі і тому
в Берліні Цей термінал як не бінарна
людина відбувся
набагато легше ніж він відбувся в
Україні
[музика]
ти думаєш
віднесення українського суспільства та в
тому числі церкви зміниться до
квіркомуніці після закінчення війни
Я думаю що воно має змінитись тому що
багатоклір людей зараз на війні також
якщо Україна буде в Євросоюзі то будуть
прийняті закони які забороняють
наприклад насилля то звісно люди
буде менше насилля щодо аквіру людей
[музика]
Кам'яна от як вебінарної людини у Божі
відбувся вже тут в Берліні в Україні
Вона відчувала себе занадто незахищеною
для цього для себе і для своєї партнерки
вона сподівається що гомофобія буде
заборонена в Україні особливо на
законодавчому рівні
мені здавалося що це буде такий знаєш 4
циліндри я зробила пропозицію мої
партнерці декілька місяців назад і ми
плануємо одруження в Данії І наприклад
ці документи і наш сертифікат про
одруження не буде їсти в Україні Я хочу
щоб наше одруження було дійсно в Україні
і
мені здається що
з іншим вже можна працювати Тому що Київ
- це дуже вірне місце це місто там
багатоклір людей і
україна має величезний потенціал Я дуже
сподіваюся що українське суспільство
знайде в собі мужність і силу придбати
про всіх потім
[музика]
навіть війну Київ залишається для мене
містом натхнення я відчуваю що тут моє
місце сили
[музика]
попри те що життя в Україні зараз це
суцільні зруйновані змінені плани тут
мої друзі мої родина мій дім
[оплески]
[музика]
знайомі обличчя на вулиці в яких так
багато світу енергії і Як приємно бути
частиною цієї сили
[музика]
мої бажання щодо України щодо
майбутнього України це
вступ до Євросоюзу та прийняття
анти
гомофобних і антикрізфобних і
трансформерних законів а також
прийняття
одностатевих шлюбів мені хочеться знову
побачити свою квартиру хочеться знову
побачити свої старі дитячі фотографії
зустрітися з друзями в рідному місті і
звичайно поїхати на море
[музика]